underneath this heading I want you to
write a single word which is why now I'm
pre-empting this question because I
teach math so all the time I get asked
why wish why why are we learning this
like what's the point in some ways I
don't need to ask that question of you
guys because as you're 11 students you
have chosen to do this subject you're
like well this is kind of what I signed
up for but at the same time I think you
will gain something even if it's not a
burning question in the back of your
mind or the front of your mind I think
you'll gain something about knowing why
the quadratic function is something that
we care about okay
in mathematics you know a lot of topics
I listed some of them just now okay
mathematics is know more about those
topics like algebra trig geometry
quadratic functions it's know more about
those topics than say modern history is
about World War two or or English is
about a fellow Othello World War two
they're just what I would call a useful
Avenue along which to explore the ideas
and the concepts and the skills that the
course is really about does that make
sense so English is about being able to
communicate through a narrative with
compelling characters and be able to
help someone change your perspective on
the way they view the world right and
you can pick any poem any any text any
movie to do that so long as it's got
sufficient interesting material with it
it's not something well crafted and any
kind of historical situation can also
tell you what you need to know in terms
of the tools of long history now the
topics in the math course that you guys
are studying are exactly the same we
could have chosen like there are you
might experience by 10% 10% of all of
the different topics of mathematics
throughout like it takes 13 years and
all you even get to look into is 10%
because there's 90% of stuff which is
just like it either is either too hard
takes too long is too abstract we just
don't have the time and
we're very selective so how do you code
Radek functions make the cut
why are they something which we thought
like a fellow like World War two okay
this is going to be really useful
quadratic functions are well you can all
are right for me the general quadratic
function the quadratic function that for
different values is every single
quadratic function out there I would
probably start it off with a x squared
and then how would I finish it plus okay
I'm not even a general form of straight
line this is just a function of X so
it's actually just going to be X plus C
okay so this is a general quadratic
function you can see because we're we
have function notation now we developed
earlier than you so that's what I'm
using okay what makes this a quadratic
function that's not a rhetorical
question what makes this quadratic yeah
yeah this this index right here that
power once you've got that two there in
some ways it actually doesn't matter
what other stuff is there it's just
peripheral the two is what characterizes
this that's a quadratic
okay now quadratics are more complicated
than if I change that power if I make it
smaller I any straight line I suppose
since I've got you know why is the
subject any straight line could be
written in this one right if I'm
thinking about functions of X you change
the power you reduce it and you have an
object of accordingly less complexity
it's a much simpler object and that's
why you guys start learning about them
like back in year eight I think you're
actually the first time you have to draw
one of these you know a picture oh
that's when you go down in complexity
it's nice it's accessible but it's sort
of boring then do very much which is why
you move on from them quite quickly if
on the other hand you go up you've never
really had to work with this and I'll
show you the reason why
what would the general form of a cubic
but how would you invent a way to write
that or just out yet yep
such imaginative creatures
mathematicians right so this is this
could be any cubic right now one of the
reasons why you know we never really
forget the general form of a cubed is
because while this object here
is accessible and boring and simple
almost too simple this object here
despite just changing the power by one
just completely goes off the deep end
okay
example this thing here if you want to
find when it's equal to zero if you want
to find when this whole thing is equal
to zero we have a formula for this right
what is the formula X is equal to minus
B plus or minus very very good all over
okay so the quadratic formula is fairly
nice and easy to act in that's why you
already know what it is there's a
formula for cubics as well and as soon
as I show it to you you will realize why
we don't let it
this is a formula for a cubic X is equal
to the cube root on and then and then it
begins okay now when you have a look at
this it's just like oh yeah okay as a
person in charge of deciding what's
going to make the cut what kinds of
topics are we going to have a look at
like should we go to the next level
because because we did this level linear
functions we spent like three four weeks
on now we're going to this are we going
to go this way yeah I don't think we
want to go that far right there is also
a quartic formula which as you could
imagine is even worse than that and then
when you get to a power of five what
would you call the power of five five
you call it a quintic guess what
amazingly there not only is no formula
there's no quintic formula
mathematicians have proved there can't
be a quintic problem they've proved it's
actually impossible which is kind of
crazy like we prove that something can't
be so therefore you guys are the story
of Goldilocks right golly awesome three
bears okay quadratic functions are in
the Goldilocks zone when we think about
polynomials they're not too boring and
simple they actually do something
interesting in terms of derivatives
turning-point like a thing and they're
not too hard they're not inaccessible
that's why we spend so much time on
these objects because they are something
you can manipulate but they
interesting enough that when you do
manipulate them you get cool speeds out
of it okay